hey what's up one of the most asked
questions I get as a model is hey Daniel
what is the best diet plan for weight
loss? Or what do you eat as a model to
stay in shape? So in this video I'm gonna
share that with you and we're starting
right now
hey I'm Daniel and welcome to DLM model
lifestyle now if you watch until the end
of the video I'll give you five extra
bonus tips to lose weight now let's
start. The reason why people struggle so
much to lose weight is because there are
thousands of quick fixes and diets out
there. Some might work but some is not
really that good and people will always
pick up the weight if they don't change
to a healthy lifestyle. So the best diet
for weight loss is adapting to a healthy
lifestyle. Now this is how it works I'm
gonna give you 10 basic lifestyle
changes that you need to make: First you
gotta stay away from all kinds of sugar
now sugar is actually the biggest drug
in the world killing more people than
heroin and cocaine combined it contains
huge amounts of calories with no
essential nutrients it not only makes
you fat but it also increases the risk
of diabetes heart disease cancer and
many other health problems sleep more
consistent and try to get between seven
and eight hours of sleep every day if
you don't sleep enough your cortisol
levels rises cortisol is your stress
hormone that is frequently associated
with fat gain not enough sleep also
causes your body to produce ghrelin
which is a hormone that increases
appetite and promotes fat storage you
need to know what kind of food is
healthy to eat so you have to eat the
following healthy foods number 1 is
nuts they're one of the best snacks that
you can eat they are loaded with
antioxidants help you to lose weight and
lowers cholesterol and if you can choose
almonds over other nuts because they are
the healthiest
number 2 is beans and legumes leg
amuse leg anis (legumes) like you know what I mean
beans are packed with protein fiber iron
and B vitamins they will help you to
lose weight and prevent heart disease
fight cancer and lower cholesterol but
don't eat too much of them because they
can also cause migraines and also raise
your blood pressure. 3 is dairy
products now I know there's a lot of
people that might be against dairy
products and that's fine that's your
choice but the majority of studies
indicate that good quality dairy
products can help with weight loss and
improve body composition and it is also
a superfood for your bones
number 4 is oatmeal oats is one of
the healthiest grains that you can
choose natural oatmeal without added
sugar it can help with weight loss it
enhances your immune system and
stabilize blood sugar and it also
contains a good amount of fiber protein
and vitamin b-complex
number 5 eggs now eggs are amazing
for weight loss one big egg contains
only 77 calories it is a superfood that
is rich in protein healthy fats vitamins
and minerals
alright number 6 is lean protein having
enough lean protein fuels fat burning
lean protein also strengthens your
immune system and repairs damaged cells
while it also manufactures hormones
number 7 is you got to choose the
right kinds of oils choose olive oil or
coconut oil instead of sunflower or
canola or all those other kind of bad
oils real olive oil is packed with
vitamin E and antioxidants and coconut
oil is high in medium chain
triglycerides which are fatty acids that
are metabolized differently than most
other fats and this leads to beneficial
effects on metabolism and helping you to
lose weight
number 8 is eat whole grains or
wholewheat, wholewheat bread and pasta has
more fiber and is more filling compared
to normal bread or pasta people that
choose whole-wheat products have lower
risk of obesity and lower cholesterol
stay away from any kind of refined
starches where the inner and outer most
layers of the grain are removed when
they make the flour which causes it to
lose its fiber and protein now these
fine starches act a lot like sugar once
your body starts to digest them
number 9 is whey protein but only use
it if you are working out whey protein
is probably the best source to help you
with weight loss. Why? Well because it is
the most thermogenic food source let me
explain it more plainly whey protein
burns the most calories after you
consume it I will link my preferred
weight protein in the video description
down below so you can go ahead and check
it out number 10 is fruit
research shows that fruit can help you
with your weight loss journey if you
have a sweet craving choose fruits
because it contains natural fructose and
fiber healthy fruits also reduces the
risk of cancer diabetes stroke heart
attack and high blood pressure the fruit
that will help you to lose weight the
most are berries and grapefruit yes
there are other fruits as well but those
are my favorite
next is leafy green vegetables they
include kale spinach collards Swiss
chard and a few others now they are very
low in calories while being loaded with
fiber eating leafy greens is perfect for
increasing the volume of your meals
without increasing the calories they are
very high in many vitamins antioxidants
and minerals which aids in fat burn
alright now that you know the basic kind
of food types to eat let's move on to
lifestyle change
number seven stay away from soft drinks
like coke. Why? It is very scary how most
of the world's population became used to
drinking soda every day it acts like a
type of drug because it is addictive and
just after 16 minutes it can deplete
nutrients make you more hungry and also
thirsty for more it is crazy to know
that there is around 40 grams of sugar
in one can of coke which is around 8
teaspoons of sugar when you drink Coke
or other soft drinks your blood sugar
levels increases dramatically causing a
burst of insulin the liver then turns
the high amount of sugar circulating in
your body into fat
drink between one and a half to two
liters of water per day water is not
only good for flushing toxins from your
body but it also helps you to lose
weight recent studies shows that water
actually speeds up weight loss water
contains no calories and it boosts your
metabolism you have to read your food
labels oh guys it is so important the
food industry has changed a lot the food
industry is there to make money and they
are very clever in their marketing to
mislead you here are just a few crazy
facts that you did not know if you see
low-fat or fat-free products it does not
mean that it is more healthy most
products take out the fat but then they
add more sugar for the taste which is
far far worse and then when some
products say that it is sugar-free there
are all kinds of artificial sweeteners
that causes all sorts of controversy and
it may actually cause weight gain even
free juice went from health food to junk
food because the food industry started
to add sugar and water they even add
sugar to most Breads so check the labels
for sugar and fructose syrup which is
actually a kind of sugar from all the
options of healthy food that you have
choose and eat the food that makes you
happy because starting a new diet for
most people is easier said than done
right so the trick is you have to learn
how to make healthy food into delicious
food that you love. To make this a
lasting habit start with small changes
and try new ways of thinking about food
drink more green tea and coffee yes I
said it coffee I know there's a lot of
people that might disagree with me about
coffee but here goes
unlike soft drinks coffee is actually
good for you if you don't drink too much
and don't add any sugar coffee gives
your metabolism a good boost which helps
you to lose more weight and coffee has a
huge amount of antioxidants gives you a
boost to your short-term memory while it
also lowers the risk of certain cancers
and diabetes coffee can also enhance
exercise performance and curbs
depression it even protects you against
gout now some people believe that coffee
is very bad for you but at the same time
those same people drink sugar loaded
drinks like Coke which is a lot worse
now let's look at green tea green tea is
well known for its weight loss effects
right but what you might not know is
that it also improves brain function
while it lowers the risk of cancer
Alzheimer's and Parkinson's green tea
also kills certain bacteria like the
bacteria that causes bad breath and it
lowers the risk of infection
try intermittent fasting to lose more
weight in my opinion it is one of the best
diets out there that lowers insulin and
blood sugar levels while at the same
time it also raises your glucagon levels
which helps you to lose more weight
faster now there are six popular ways to
do intermittent fasting and I would
suggest the 16/8 method what does that
mean well it means that you fast for 16
hours and the other eight hours you eat
yeah I know it sounds rough but you can
do it if you don't eat anything after
dinner and skipping your breakfast but
you can of course drink water or black
coffee during the fast and just be
careful before you try intermittent
fasting if you're a beginner because you
might get headaches heartburn or you
might start binge eating drinking too
much coffee or not eating enough also
some people find it very hard to sleep
to be honest I don't like any kind of
diets that restrict me in any kind of
way sometimes I eat between five and six
times per day if I really feel like it
and I don't pick up any weight if I just eat
small portion sizes and if I make the
portion sizes even smaller
I end up losing weight yeah I know there's a
lot of people that won't agree with me
and they say hey Daniel but your insulin
levels if you eat too much and then
there's no way you can lose weight but
look at me I'm skinny I'll lose weight
eat a cheap meal every now and then
because let's be honest the reason why
most people struggle to lose weight is
because of what's going on in their head
it is psychological for example I hate
counting the exact calories of
everything that I eat so I don't do it
another example is I love pizza
so every once in a while I will go and
have my pizza and I will enjoy it I
won't feel guilty about it so if you
started this lifestyle change and it's
very hard for you at the beginning then
reward yourself with a delicious pizza
or anything else you like but hey just
don't overdo it once a week is enough
alright now I told you if you watch the
video right until the end I'll give you
five quick bonus tips for losing weight
so here goes first one drink a big
glass of water first thing when you wake
up in the morning when you sleep your
metabolism slows down so when you drink
a glass of water as soon as you wake up
it fires up your metabolism at nighttime
your body repairs itself and cast out
all kinds of toxins from your body so
when you drink water on an empty stomach
early in the morning it flushes out
these toxins second step do your workout
before you have your breakfast if you
workout before breakfast your body burns
a lot more fat however some people do
not like to exercise without having
breakfast because they feel very low in
energy so it is up to you you have to
enjoy the lifestyle to keep you
motivated in the long run don't do any
unnecessary things that breaks you down
emotionally so that you might change
back to your old habits if you can
make a change now if you want to start
working out at home I have added a link
in the video description where I show
you my best home workout equipment so
you can go and check it out tip number
three if you wanna lose weight quicker
just eat lean protein and green
vegetables cut out all the carbs for a
few days by cutting out all starchy
carbs and other foods except lean
protein and green vegetables you will
boost your weight loss in
but do not do it too long because your
body will also need other foods as well
number four
eat your food slowly studies found that
people who are fat chew their food less
than people with normal weight to eat
your food slower you need to chew your
food at least several times before you
eat tip number five eat smaller portions
if you create a habit of eating smaller
portions then you will consume less
calories which results in faster weight
loss think of it in this way if you want
to be 60 kilograms but you still eat the
portion sizes of someone that is 80
kilograms what do you think is gonna
happen alright if you liked the video
give it a thumbs up subscribe and click
the notification bell so you won't miss
any new videos and that's it cheers guys